[Music]
live via the computer machine to your
phone or other such device I'm Dave
Ruben this is the Ruben report and it's
Friday which means we've got another
round table Extravaganza for you joining
me today is is the host of the news and
why it matters on Blaze TV Sarah
Gonzalez and the editor-in-chief of the
post-millennial liby Emmons ladies
welcome back to the Ruben report thank
you thanks for having us you're a rare
Duo that we've put on this show together
more than once usually we separate
people in perpetuity but we talked to
the team and they said no we're going to
let them try it again so here we go uh
obviously guys a lot of fights this week
internal fights mostly Republic
destroying Republicans which is not good
for anyone but here we are of course the
big one was the gates vers McCarthy
thing uh another one that was going
viral yesterday uh was Anne couter was
on Patrick Bet David's podcast and they
got into it about Trump and Dan santis
uh and then DeSantis ramping up the
attacks on Trump and then finally we
will end with Karin jeanpierre vers
Karin
jeanpierre uh but let's start with let's
start with what's going on over at the
house as you guys know Kevin MTH marthy
is no longer the majority leader little
info from the daily wire for those of
you catching up house Speaker Kevin
McCarthy was forced to vacate the
speakership on Tuesday after Democrats
voted in support of Representative Matt
Gates's motion to vacate the speakership
the 216 to 210 vote Mark the first time
in US history that the house has ever
removed a speaker the last time that a
speaker ship was even challenged was
more than 110 years ago go the other
seven Republicans who sided with house
Democrats included Andy bigs Ken Buck
Eli crane Bob good Matt Rosendale Tim
berett uh Nancy mace and Patrick McKenry
uh and uh oh no sorry Patrick McKenry
has been named speaker prot tempor so
he's temporary speaker to preside over
the house until a new speaker is named
likely uh next week uh ladies before we
get into any of the video on this Sarah
you first uh what do you think uh the
rep Republicans are fighting the
Republicans Gates is siding with the
Dems at least temporarily to make this
thing happen uh but perhaps this will
strengthen the Republican Party in the
long term yeah I mean I I think maybe
this is an unpopular opinion here I'm
not sure but um I think that it's
important to to remember they built in
these you know motions the motion to
vacate they lowered the threshold for
that for this very reason right and so I
I mean I understand that having a game
plan probably would have been a little
wiser maybe communicating that to the
rest of us so what is the game plan once
you get Kevin McCarthy out of office but
I do think that it was time that someone
holds someone accountable who wears a
Ukraine pin still and puts Ukraine
pocket square uh in his jacket that you
know this is not something that uh the
the the overall Republican party uh is
in favor of they haven't done much to
secure the Border if anything I would
argue they've had two and a half years
to do it I mean there have been multiple
failures that Kevin McCarthy has had
promises that he has not kept and so I
did I was in favor of someone holding
him accountable someone doing something
about it um and you know I thought
perhaps maybe there were some backdoor
conversations with Jim Jordan uh you
know and maybe Matt Gates went to him
and said hey this is what I want to do
if I'm successful you should vote for
Kevin McCarthy so you're not a bad guy
and then maybe we can get you in I
wonder if that was a conversation that
was had but I think overall um you're
really seeing when you see Hillary
Clinton come out and call Matt Gates you
know uh bad names say that Matt Gates
should be held accountable say that Matt
Gates shouldn't have done what he did I
I don't what more proof do you need that
Matt Gates is fighting the uni party in
Washington DC than Hillary Clinton and
Kevin McCarthy agreeing that Matt Gates
is the bad guy here um I I know that
people are saying that he's fundraising
off of it I think that's just a smart
thing to do politically but I wouldn't
say that it was the reason that he did
what he did and I certainly think if not
now then when right we'll get more to
we'll get more on Jim Jordan in just a
second but uh Libby the idea that he's
working with literally every Democrat
you know everyone always says we want
more
bipartisanship uh but do you think he
had to offer the Democrats something to
make this happen or or do you think that
their calculation was just hey let's
just do anything that will make the
Republicans look crazy and out of
control yeah I think the Democrats went
along with Gates because they wanted to
mess stuff up and so did Gates and
that's what they were doing but I do
think that there's some concern and when
we look at the house and we say hey they
haven't done what we wanted them to do
they are a majority in the house they
cannot get anything through to the
Senate if the Senate doesn't pick it up
and there's no guarantee that the White
House would sign off on any of the
Border legislation or anything else that
they try to push through so it is
important it is necessary for the GOP in
Congress to work with Democrats whether
in the house or the Senate to make deals
and get things passed otherwise they're
just passing laws and passing law laws
and it doesn't really matter because
they're not going to get picked up right
and they're not actually going to be
enacted so that is a concern they had
McCarthy McCarthy was able to work with
Democrats um as I said I think that
That's essential because otherwise
nothing happens and now they're going to
go into a situation where they have
absolutely no Goodwill with any Democrat
at all who is necessary to get things um
to get things passed so I do think we
are potentially looking at a situation
where in 45 days we have a government
shutdown um I think that's something
that Gates and the others wanted and
wanted to express that they wanted with
their tyranny of the minority which of
course is what that Jeffersonian rule
allows for I think um you know that's
what that's that's what that's about but
are we going to see a government
shutdown in 45 days I also think it's
important to note that while Gates was
discussing how he didn't want any more
funding for Ukraine which is very
popular among the Bas many Americans are
done with this war after having spent
$13 billion dollar on it in fact a PO um
a New York Post editorial board column
talked about how important it is to keep
spending on the war because we've
already spent $13 billion which is
absolutely the most insane position like
oh let's money money yeah it's it's
really not uh so I think that's good but
there wasn't any Ukraine funding in that
45 day stop gap which was a huge deal so
now what are we going to look at you
have Biden promising that he's going to
get funding out you have zalinsky uh
reassuring allies that us Aid is not
going to dry up they're of course
probably very concerned and they're
trying to figure out other ways maybe
get another uh Sam bankman freed style
company over there to do some Kickbacks
with Payment Processing anyways um yeah
I have concerns about where we go from
here this is the people's house and I
think it would behoove our
representatives to remember that the
funny part of all this yeah you real
quick though you know the funny part of
this of course is that the Democrats
have been far more for the war now the
Republicans have to and McConnell's
throwing money and everything else so
ironically gates in an effort which I do
believe him on that we'll show a clip of
him in just a second I do believe that
this was about funding mostly for ukra
which I'm complet I think the three of
us are probably on the same page and
most of my audiences too it's like
enough is enough it was way too much
already um and we should be funding the
the the border which Sarah you're in
Texas so you can talk about that as well
um but now he sided with the democ R Who
are all for this war Sarah yeah no I was
just going to add to that that like uh
Libby's overall point I think I I
typically would agree with when it comes
to bipartisanship and having to work
with the other side I just personally
feel like we're we're living in a time
where I don't really want to agree with
the de the Democrats have become so
radical I don't know what I want to be
bipartisan on on with them right like
they want to spend all of our money in
Ukraine they don't don't want to secure
the Border they want to you know uh turn
all of our well I don't know how to say
this on YouTube they want to you could
go whatever you want to say go ahead and
say it they don't believe in biology
they don't believe in biology I'll just
say that um the things that they you
know want to do to to the children and
so I just I'm not there's not much that
I want our side to agree with them on
and and if that means the government
shuts down for a little while I
personally am all for that because why
why why take the power back in the house
house uh Republicans being why have that
that power and not wield it for
something and I I just that that's just
where I'm at personally I obviously the
system was set up so that we could be
bipartisan um and and come to agreements
on stuff but I just feel like the
Democrats always when they get the power
they wield it and they shove it down our
throats and we're always so concerned
about well we have to go along to get
along and we have to agree with them
sometime and I'm just it just feels like
we're coming from a position of weakness
and I would just like to see that power
wielded which I think is why I was happy
that something happened right well the
the fact that every Democrat voted with
the quote unquote farri right Matt gates
to take out the more moderate McCarthy
tells you that did you guys happen to
see we played a clip of Thomas Massie
who's been in Congress for years who was
against John Boehner when he was the
Republican uh leader of the house he was
against Paul Ryan when he was the
Republican leader of the house and what
Massie said I thought was really
interesting he said this has been the
most conservative uh Republican majority
that he's seen in his years now it may
not be good enough for everybody but his
argument was you leave McCarthy because
he actually is doing some of those
things do you think that flies at all
liby or the bases just had it either way
and they're just like ah burn it down it
doesn't so maybe he was okay and Trump
did Back Him by the way so it's it's a
little bizarre I think there's a lot of
a burn it down mentality and I
appreciate what Sarah said the Democrats
do know how to unify and shove their
points down our throats that has a lot
to do do with them having something of a
hive mind whereas the conservatives tend
to insist on thinking independently uh
which is which I thoroughly agree with
um but yeah we do have a rather
conservative majority I think that
that's a good thing I appreciate the
staunch determination to not go along
with things as existential as the
Ukraine war as border security um and on
you know as transing kids and in fact
abortion you know to a large I
appreciate that very much um I just have
concerns that we're going to see uh a
thorough hold up in government now on
the one hand what that is is that's
that's what William F Buckley wanted you
know what is it stand a thwart history
and yell stock um and maybe it is a good
time to just say you know what hold on
everybody we're not going to just run
through everything and push everything
through just so that things get done
maybe this is a great time to take a
real thorough assessment of where this
nation is going what's best for her
citizens and what's best for you know
our place in the world I wrong with that
for the record I'd have no problem with
a 45 day shutdown or maybe a 365 day
shutdown and cut all of their salaries
and how about this if you guys are so
you guys are so crossed up in budgets
how about you cut taxes on literally
everybody for 20 25% and then we'll
figure it out but why don't we throw to
Matt Gates because here here he is
making his argument for exactly what
happened results on the border the
border is a disaster really something I
don't think you're going to be
campaigning on that you fix the Border
second you said you streamlined
regulations what the gentleman from
Louisiana doesn't tell you is that all
of the regulatory reform he was just
bragging about is wable by the stroke of
a pen of someone in the Biden White
House do you really think you've got
anything for that it's a total joke and
then finally the welfare to work that
the gentleman from Louisiana said we got
the welfare programs that they said that
they streamlined with their welfare to
work stuff they're actually going to
grow because while they did work
requirements they blew out those
programs with expanded eligibility I'm
real glad you guys didn't put work
requirements on Medicaid it probably
would have resulted in Medicaid
expansion and when it comes to how those
raised money I take no lecture on asking
patriotic Americans to weigh in and
contribute to this fight from those who
would gravel and bend knee for the
lobbyists and special interests who own
our leadership who have oh boo all you
want who have hollowed out this town and
have borrowed against the future of our
future Generations I'll be happy to fund
my political operation through the work
of hardworking Americans 10 and 20 and
$30 at a time and you all keep showing
up at the lobbyist
fundraisers you know Sarah I think most
people hear that and probably agree with
the spirit of it like this place is
broken so many of you feel like sellouts
and everything else but I also feel like
there's like a little twang of like oh
I'm the good guy all of you are selling
out it's a little bit like what re did
in that first debate like I'm the honest
one you guys are all bought and sold
that seems a little disingenuous to me
like it can't be that everyone else is
evil as frustrated as we are with all
them right or with many of them no yeah
I mean I I I agree with you and
obviously there's a an element of
theatrics uh that Matt Gates imposes
anytime he is on the floor um but I I
don't dis the thing is is like I don't
disagree with his overall point and I
think that like you said Dave he's
speaking to the everyday Americans or
the everyday conservatives who are so
tired of seeing what's going on in
Washington they're so tired of these
people who pretend like they dislike
each other whenever the cameras are on
and when the cameras turn off they go
out to dinner and have drinks together
and laugh together um the fight in uh
the the the heartland of the country not
in Washington DC is very very real and
you have the FBI and the doj actually
targeting uh Donald Trump's supporters
you have them throwing people in jail
for waving their flags at the capital on
January 6th and you know the blaze has
done some really great investigative
journalism on uh you know perjury that
perhaps has taken place when it comes to
Nancy Pelosi's security uh people who
were in The know who did this seemingly
intentionally to punish Donald Trump's
supporters and so I think that when you
look at what the other side is doing to
us it's like I don't really care at the
end of the day if Matt Gates puts on a
little bit of theatrics and goes out
there and says what we are all thinking
which is we're tired of guys working for
lobbyists we're tired of you guys doing
backro deals with each other which is
not what we put you in office to do and
we want you to work for we the people
and if if some politics goes into that
and some theatrics goes into that at the
end of the day I just bake that into the
deal of you know what we need someone
who brings the chaos that we're feeling
as Americans in America we need someone
to bring that chaos to Washington DC so
the elitist can feel that same chaos
that we're feeling every day I think
that's solid an is I think just in the
last hour by the way uh Donald Trump has
endorsed Jim Jordan I've had Jim Jordan
on the show many times I think he's a
good guy he's great on free speech and
the tech stuff especially he doesn't
want to fund Ukraine here's a little uh
video of Jim Jordan yesterday talking
about what his policy would be related
to Ukraine well let's talk a little bit
about aid for Ukraine because there are
a number of conservatives who say in
your conference that they will sync any
candidate for speaker who does support
aid for Ukraine so where are you on that
I've been clear all along why should we
be sending American tax dollars to
Ukraine when we don't even know what the
goal is no one can tell me what the
objective is is it is it some kind of
negotiated piece is it driving them out
of the eastern Ukraine is it driving
them out of Crimea which they've had for
10 years now they took during the Obama
Administration what is the objective and
so until you can tell me the goal I
don't think we should continue to send
money there particularly when we have
the problems we have on our border so
that's fundamental uh I just think
that's front and center and then second
how is the money that's already been
sent how is it how has it been spent
what kind of waste is going those are
two fundamental questions that I think
the American taxpayers want to know the
answers to before they send any more of
their hard-earned money there
particularly you're sending money there
to protect Ukraine's border when we got
the situation we have on our border so
those are the fundamental questions that
we should get answered before we even
think about sending more money Libby
sometimes it's find it's hard to find
white pills these days but that seems
like a white pill to me like if we end
up with him as the speaker like
that seems pretty solid right yeah you
know I thoroughly agree on that Jordan
was one of the names floated during that
epic speaker fight in January uh he was
nominated a couple of times I think even
Matt Gates nominated him a couple of
times along with Byron Donalds and
Donald Trump and you know his pet cat or
whatever else but um yeah I think I
think Jordan is actually a pretty
standup guy which is rare for a
politician and I appreciate his
Integrity on wanting to know where the
money in Ukraine has already been spent
and what the plan is for getting out of
this situation we hear Biden repeatedly
say we're in it for as long as it takes
but we don't know as long as it takes to
what and I think that that's clearly so
important you also had uh the House and
Senate I believe both vote against um an
audit for what happened to the money so
far we see Ukraine which is a country
that is known for decades to be a very
corrupt Nation we see um defense
ministers getting fired and we see
consistent Staffing changes we see
zalinski actually putting in prison one
of the guys who funded not only his
acting career but his political career
and now he's going after him he's the
big bad oligarch you know probably
because he got all the money he could
out of that guy so it's time to get rid
of him um we don't know where the money
is going in Ukraine we don't know what
the plan is for this war we do know that
the Pentagon reached out to Congress and
said that they're going to have trouble
replacing the weapons they have already
sent to Ukraine by bid has repeatedly
promised no tanks no f-16s no uh Rockets
you know no long range missiles um these
things these promises have consistently
been broken we don't know what else is
going to be broken there's in fact only
one promise left that Biden has made
that he hasn't broken with regard to the
war in Ukraine and that's that we won't
be going to war with Russia so if we
continue on this course we can expect
Biden to break that promise as well and
before we know it we're going to have an
underfunded military situation here at
home with our own troops we're going to
be continuing to pour money into Ukraine
and we're going to have our border
completely decimated and our nation
overrun so and by the way by way a lot
that stuff forther at least from where
I'm sitting at some point if you've
given somebody like hundreds of billions
of dollars to be at war with say Russia
you're kind of at war with Russia either
whether you signed the document or not
but let's go from the gates uh McCarthy
fight to this other fight that's brewing
with the Republicans right now that I
think clearly for the next year is going
to overshadow everything uh which is the
Trump to Santa situation because uh an
couter who was one of the main Trump
backers like one of the first people
back in 2015 to back Trump uh she's no
longer into Donald uh she's she's moved
to Camp to santis she was on Patrick Bet
David's podcast yesterday and they got
into it it got it got pretty uh pretty
Tiffy you could say uh over some of
Trump's perceived failures at least from
perspective he is that stupid
respectfully you sound bitter now and
and and the reason why he don't lie to
us when you're campaigning and getting
our votes B you sound like a a battered
woman making excuses well maybe he won't
hit me next time it's been four years
he's been beating the crap out of you he
had four years Patrick four years two
with a republican Congress oh but I know
he he could have not hit me but maybe he
was thinking he was waiting for our
golden anniversary to stop hitting me he
was just waiting for that perfect time
no he had four years he didn't build it
I don't know what other proof you could
possibly besides Co that was very big in
2020 and you say and this reminds me
that you want you want to feel safe and
boy we don't feel safe now especially
New York and la oh God Philly all these
places San Francisco I mean if you're a
city person like I am where where do you
go anyway um and that was the George
Floyd May 25th 2020 change the world we
suddenly we have to release all the
criminals among other things
um one place you would have been safe in
2020 was in Florida thank you Ronda
Santos passing law after law where you
can shoot looters anti- rting laws I
mean there were specific actions he took
that made that meant there were no riots
and no police stations were burnt down
and you did not have police being
assaulted what did the commanderin-chief
do what did Trump do he sent out Tweets
in all caps Law and Order point one
point two at the first debate what did
Donald Trump say to Joe Biden you called
them super Predators I'm releasing
people from prison how about the first
step act thank you Jared he's releasing
criminals you want to feel safe Donald
Trump ain't your guy I mean man she went
on and on and on and I don't think she
said anything that was untrue there
don't you have to keep in mind she also
wrote a book called in Trump We Trust
she was also on Bill Maher in 20 5
saying Trump was going to be the nominee
when he was polling at like 20 25%
something like that uh Sarah like I I
don't even know what to say wow cter
yeah yeah that's quite the uh quite the
turnaround look I know for an cter her
number one issue was the border and you
know she is very upset that the border
is not secure I will say look Trump
saying we're going to make Mexico pay
for it I always found to be Preposterous
because anyone who understands how
things work knows you can't force
another country to pay for he's admitted
it's a lie since then in essence he
didn't say lie yeah and and I thought
that that was that was a stumble I
thought for him to say oh come on you
couldn't have possibly believed that
because I mean you want to believe that
when a politician is telling you that
they're going to do something that they
actually intend to do it um so I did
think that that was a stumble for his
campaign and I I don't blame her for
being upset I will say he did have a
Congress that fought him a lot of the
time on funding the border wall uh every
step of the way but still she has very
aable critiques of Donald Trump that I
think he needs to answer for I think
that when you add in all of the co stuff
too Donald Trump was very good and very
effective at a lot of things Donald
Trump also had a lot of weaknesses
specifically during coid that I think
that he needs to answer for and I think
that the problem is that not only has he
not answered for them he's actually
doubled down on a lot of them uh he's
doubled down on the vaccine still when
it's just this bizarre uh place where
you know you have the majority of
conservatives now who are totally
against this vaccine but still are okay
with trump touting it they have
questions about you know uh the efficacy
and things of that nature but they still
uh they back Trump on it so it's a very
weird dynamic here where we're willing
to admit that he failed on these things
but we're not willing to hold his feet
to the fire on them um I I maybe that's
because you know I'm sure you guys are
very familiar with this I'm I try to
call balls and Strikes the way that I
see them on my show and I will you know
I will maybe gently criticize Trump on
something that I thought that he could
have done better I don't like his
answers on abortion uh you know I I
don't like a lot of his answers that
he's given Megan Kelly and things like
that and when I'll say like hey I don't
like hearing that from him I would have
have liked to hear stronger conservative
language I get called a disantis shill
if I if I criticize disantis I get
called a Trumper and I'm like I can't
win but at the end of the day I just
want someone to say what they mean and
mean what they say and follow through on
what they're saying Sarah you don't you
don't need my advice as a broadcaster
but that's all you can do right you can
just tell people what you think and the
chips fall where they may but Libby what
do you think about that point where it
seems to me that Trump has had some
major missteps in some of these
interviews with Megan Kelly and a bunch
of others and if anyone says anything
about them we're we're just not allowed
to because the Bas will be angry at you
uh even when an makes a series of good
points yeah I think that we're in a
really difficult position on the
conservative side um where we have two
candidates who um primarily are the ones
that everyone thinks about Dan santis
and Trump and the two of them can't get
along at all and we're just going to
destroy ourselves and Destroy Congress
and Destroy any standing that we have of
credibility and I think that that's a
shame um cult well I would say that
there's one who's consistently lying
about the other like I don't think it's
exactly you don't think it's perfectly
symmetrical do you I think there's a lot
of attacks going on and I haven't dug in
into either of the attacks I hate the
attack language and I I agree with Sarah
I want people to say what they mean and
I want people to be direct and honest
that's that's all I'm really interested
in in a politician of course it's the
those are the two things that
politicians are most incapable of
delivering but I think that it's you
know the polling keeps coming out in
Trump's favor and it's it's interesting
to wonder why that is you have Hillary
Clinton coming out saying that the Maga
base needs to be deprogrammed she's
absolutely shocked that no matter how
much gets thrown at Donald Trump the
polls still stand up in his favor I
wonder though it's interesting you were
talking about how uh you can't speak out
against Trump I think in a lot of ways
you can't speak out against D santis
either either way you get slammed by
somebody which is why it's key to just
say this is the thing that happened what
do you guys think a lot of this election
a lot of the entirety of 20124 is in the
hands of the base the Grassroots on
either side Democrat or Republican side
if the country is pretty evenly split so
it's really going to be quite a battle
for those people for the Americans to
determine who's going to come out on top
what perspective is going to win the day
and I don't think that's clear at all um
when I look at one of the things that
was so uh key about desent is was the
idea that he was more electable well as
soon as he started coming out uh saying
that he was going to run you had Joy
Reed calling him a white supremacist and
all of this using the same tired garbage
language that was unfounded against him
as they would use against Trump or
literally any front runner so what does
that say is there any way for a
Conservative candidate to gain the
support of Democrats of liberals of you
know of
Independence I think I think there is
Maybe not maybe not on MSNBC but his
election in Florida is proof of that
right like the amount of liberals former
liberals I mean you're looking at one of
them who now are I would say I'm a
hardcore Florida Republican I'm not a
Republican at a national level but
they're clear you know the guy won by 20
some odd points I want to throw to a
clip of desand this because you both
repeated a line about you want a
politician who does what he says and
says what he's going to do or flip that
the other way and here are two clips
that we put together just in the last
day or so and let's see if that's what
he's doing here a voter that goes to 10
rallies their vote counts the same as
somebody that's unenthusiastic then then
goes and votes and and we just have to
understand that and people will act like
2020 they're like you know Biden was was
such a disaster but here's the thing I
don't think I don't think anybody voted
for Biden okay they were voting against
Trump that was why they did it I mean
let's just be honest he in he energized
Democrats you could have John Kennedy
walk through the door right now and he
wouldn't energize Democrats as much as
Donald Trump does that's just the
reality what did we do in Florida with
these Democrats we defeated these
Democrats we left the Democratic Party
in Florida in a pile of
ruins they're
dead Trump endorsed Paul Ryan when we
were trying to remove him in the freedom
caucus back in 2016 Trump endorsed
McCarthy Trump endorsed McConnell for
reelection in 2020 uh I didn't do any of
those things that was Trump not me and
so here's the thing uh that is
delusional stuff look at what I've done
as Governor okay we fought the biomed
Security State there weren't very many
Republic an willing to do that we ban
gender transition surgeries for minors
not a lot of Republicans have been
willing to do that we ban Sanctuary
cities we put in E verify how many
people associated with Paul Ryan would
have sent illegal aliens to Martha's
Vineyard uh We've push back against Dei
and ESG ban Central Bank digital
currency there's not a single elected
Republican in the country who can match
that
record that's why I always says like
that's why I always say like backing him
it's making my job easy because I don't
think you heard anything that was that
was dishonest I'll let I'll let you guys
get to it but just on a quick point on
whether you can get Democrats to switch
over in Florida when Ronda santis took
over as governor in 2018 Democrats had
plus 300,000 voters registered it is now
plus
600,000 Republicans that's a
900,000 registered voter swing Sarah so
the proof is kind of in the pudding
there right yeah I I agree um he has the
track record to run off of obviously I
think the question is there are so many
other factors at play when you look at
the Dynamics of this particular campaign
season uh mostly the idea that Trump
continues to get indicted and I think
that that's just bolstering you know I
have the same um nric reactions that the
Grassroots does when you look at that
and you go well they're doing that to
him I can't believe they're doing that
to him we have to support him now look
at what the left is doing to him and so
I think that you know Ronda is running
at this unprecedented time where uh the
left is literally trying to I believe
trying to imprison one of their
political opponents who he happens to be
running against in the primary and so I
think what it comes down to is Americans
are really going to have to decide what
it is that they want do they want
someone that has a proven track record
who's done all the work in Florida that
you just mentioned uh specifically when
it comes to the voter roles specifically
when it comes to transforming a purple
State into a very heavy red state do you
want someone who says hey you know what
I I may not I may not you know uh pick
the battles that Donald Trump does I may
not tweet mean things all the time I may
not take that you know stance but at the
end of the day I get things done is that
what you want America they're going to
have to decide if they want that or if
they just want the fighter uh you know
the the guy that tweets mean things the
guy that again he had a lot of good
track record a lot of good history as
president but he also as I said before
has things he has to answer for so
I would hope that America would vote on
um say what they mean mean what they say
and delivering results I'm just not
convinced that the average American
voter appreciates that more than they
appreciate someone going on a CNN town
hall and you know attacking Caitlyn
Collins the way that they want them to
right I totally hear you like there's
sort of Competency versus the show and
that's just for the people to decide uh
I want to show you one clip of trump
yesterday because you know apparently
you know I got a great idea for you for
Sarah you at the Blaze and Libby you at
post millennial you want to do something
interesting start looking into what's
going on with these polls because I've
been checking them out on you know when
you see all these polls go through and
I've been looking at some of the data
you know that almost all of these polls
it's like 500 to a thousand people like
these are tiny tiny samples it might
just be worth doing a little dive on
that but here's Trump yesterday
apparently up by 50 points uh talking
about the guy that has no chance there's
a bad seed there he's a bad seed like
you play every once in a while you have
a bad seed you think it's good but it's
bad I mean anybody that you got elected
should support you if I help somebody if
somebody you know I help somebody and it
does happen on occasion I figure 10% of
the time you help somebody a lot then
all of a sudden you see they go against
you and you you just can't it's hard to
like those people but it happens mostly
good 90% good man the juxtaposition just
of how they speak is just becoming just
so wild and wide I mean Libby can you
think of anyone that Donald Trump has
been loyal to his whole thing is that
the santis isn't being loyal to him is
there anyone from Kaylee maani on down
uh Trump speaks a lot about loyalty but
in most cases I feel like he means
loyalty to him as opposed to necessarily
loyalty to others um no there has not
been a ton of a ton of loyalty there
although the base has been thoroughly
loyal to him and we do see that in the
polling you may have questions about the
methodology behind those polling but the
the latest RCP average shows uh Trump
leading Biden in a head-to-head matchup
and disantis trailing Biden so this is a
question if DeSantis as as you believe
obviously is the better candidate why
isn't that permeating um if Trump has
all of these faults as as you say that
he does why is that not permeating to
the uh you know down into the into the
base of the party and to the American
people um I I also agree with you though
when people voted for Biden they were
voting against Trump I know that that's
definitely true among people in my
family that were voting for Biden they
didn't like him very much they don't
like him now um but they still don't
like Trump and these are people who are
you know sort of purple in their own in
their own politics um but yeah one one
quick correction one quick correction
the one thing I was very pleased to see
was that as everyone was uh yelling for
Trump to be speaker he came out and
backed Jordan so I was very happy about
that no that was good to see and I think
my guess is the santis will back Jordan
too so maybe this gets us to a little
Unity for whatever value that that word
has anymore quick correction because I
do like to correct myself unlike CNN or
MSNBC uh the Trump speech was not from
yesterday it was from last week I know
it's a minor correction but there you go
uh but let's move on to the Border stuff
because I think putting aside all of the
Republican fights and everything else
this border situation is completely
completely insane I want to start with
this video that every single American
should have seen this video this should
have been the lead on every 6:30 NBC CBS
uh ABC news program and everything else
every cable news program but of course
it was not check out what is going on at
the Texas border this is in El Paso this
is I think two days
[Applause]
ago absolutely insane absolutely insane
there are many other videos like that we
are being told the border is secure
we've been gaslit for the last two years
with this Administration Sarah you're in
Texas I know this one's personal to you
go ahead yeah I mean what you're seeing
right there is how a republic crumbles
it it is mindboggling to me that this
Administration is so toned deaf that
they think that this could end any way
other than complete destruction of the
entire country uh you know this is why
you see people like um you know mayor
Eric Adams you see Kathy hokel you uh
you know leaders in Chicago you see all
of these blue cities blue States who
previously were like oh well we're just
Sanctuary cities cuz we just care about
immigrants we we want to bring them
bring the masses and they're finding out
oh wait a second we don't have the
economic resources to sustain this which
is the entire point and so you know I
watch this stuff and and I'm thinking
obviously I'm going to vote for whoever
the Republican candidate is sign me up
I'll crawl over broken glass to vote for
them me too but but but but I I don't
think that I can take any Republican
seriously who does not say this cannot
end in any way other than sure secure
the Border we got to do that but we have
to talk about Mass deportations I know
it's a very difficult thing for
Republican candidates to talk about I
think it feels very icky for them to
actually say the words out loud but you
look at that amount of people just in
that one video now multiply that by the
millions and millions and millions of
people just who have come in in the last
2 and a half years what is that going to
look like 10 years down the line for
this country they're taking over New
York hotels I mean we're hearing all
sorts of of stories about what a drain
they are financially just wait until you
multiply that in 10 years where does
that lead we have to get these people
out of the country and I think that
Republican candidates and just
candidates overall really need to start
talking about a a a two or three or four
pronged approach sure secure the Border
but we've got to get these people who
are coming in we have got to remove them
yeah and you're also by the way you're
making a great point which is worth
reiterating that the Democrats like Eric
Adams and all the rest Kathy hokel in
New York all of them they they literally
said come they said come and now they
got it and now they're pissed uh but the
gaslighting needs to be exposed here is
Karin jeanpierre in 2021 when a whole
bunch of us were talking about what's
going on but here she is in 2021 and
then we'll compare that to yesterday the
U president suon to lead Customs and
Border Protection said in his Senate
confirmation hearing yesterday that that
he supported the continued use of title
42 he also indicated it was his view
that certain sections of the border wall
should be finished was the president
agree well as as you know we have said
that um I I I have to look at this the
uh comments I have not seen them so I
want to make sure I I read it within
context uh but we have talked about the
border wall here in in general as as a
way uh that it's been used in in a to to
you know to to close the border and we
feel that it is a policy that doesn't
work and it's not just us uh you know
experts have said that the border wall
is not uh is not an effective policy as
far as those comments I can't comment on
that I actually I have not seen it we
feel a wall doesn't work but a wall does
work a wall is a physical thing and
you'd have to maybe walk around it or
climb over it or someone would have to
open a door which we're showing a lot of
videos lately of fences I have a fence
in front of my house it makes it more
difficult to get to my front door like
Libby so much of is just an abject
denial of reality right it is an abject
denial of reality uh when the during the
Trump Administration I think uh
immigration illegal immigration was
halted by some 80% just recently you had
the Biden Administration start selling
off lots of equipment and uh materials
that could be used to Build That Wall
they sold it off at a fraction of what
it was purchased for and now they're
saying they're going to build the wall
again they say that The Border's not
open then they say that it's open and
they're going to close it and then they
say this doesn't work and that doesn't
work and we're not trying to do any of
this other stuff we're not sending
migrants out all over the country yes we
are it's that classic thing that they do
where they say this isn't happening wait
okay it is happening and it's a good
thing right that's what they keep doing
they do that about transing kids they do
that about abortion they do it about the
border wall and what I find particularly
infuriating uh as a New Yorker um you
know that's my hometown is you have Eric
Adams saying we want the borders open
but we're going to go down there and
tell them not to
come that's not going to work you have
Kathy hokel saying like hey everyone go
somewhere else and everyone down in
Mexico and Guatemala wherever it is that
they're you know coming up from are like
hey you know what we're going to do
we're going to go to New York you know
why they're giving out free beds free
food they're going to make sure we get
jobs you had AOC out there a couple of
weeks ago in front of the Roosevelt
Hotel saying like oh let's get more work
visas for Venezuelans there's New
Yorkers that need jobs the whole point
of right to shelter law was to make sure
that Homeless New Yorkers had a place to
go to make sure that homeless families
had a place to sleep and a place to to
have their children not be sleeping
outside and now we're just we're housing
the whole world what is this this is
ludicrous and the Biden Administration
doesn't care they're not doing anything
about it they're going to push
everything in and then the next thing
you know what they're doing in a lot of
these uh States is they're saying you
know what we're going to do we're going
to get IDs for illegal immigrants you
have uh Minnesota giving out driver's
licenses New York City can get an ID
then you have city council saying
non-citizens should get the vote now
that was struck down by the you know a
high New York Court and that's great but
it's being pushed through all over the
place and now you have ice is going to
be giving out you know proper card IDs
to um to illegal immigrants and it's
it's absolutely
insane are insane it's all nuts by the
way the the real devil of what they do
the real like nasty part is that right
before the election they'll get a little
bit better and conf fuse people right so
then they will have created all of the
problems but you you can kind of feel it
happening right now we're going into we
have a year till the general election so
suddenly they're going to get a little
bit better on the border although
they're the ones that created the
problem but here now uh uh what's it
Homeland Security uh the Department of
Homeland Security is he what is he
mayorcas what's his title yes may orcus
uh Homeland Security secretary Secretary
of Homeland Security thank you he's just
such a piece I always get lost with him
because the eyebrows are so insane we're
not saying don't come we're saying don't
come now and so he did that a couple
weeks ago and then now he's saying oh
maybe we should build a wall or
something like that but Biden's saying
we shouldn't here's yesterday cringe
Jean Pierre on that uh the president
just told me that a border wall does not
work if that's the case why does his own
Department of and security secretary say
in a public notice quote there is
presently an acute and immediate need to
construct physical barriers here's what
I can say I can speak to what the
president was very clear and saying and
also what you all have been reporting
about uh about about this uh uh this
construction uh so the facts are this uh
this uh this is not new uh These funds
were appropriated in fiscal year 2019
under Republican leadership and DHS is
required by law to use the funds for
appropr appropriated purpose that's what
we're seeing this was announced back in
June by the DHS and so look we we
believe that there are better effective
ways of moving forward to secure our
border and security we our border
security and we have continuously asked
for congress uh to act uh to provide our
CBP the law enforcement uh law
enforcement at the border uh to give
them the resources they need to do their
jobs and so we're going to continue to
call on Congress we believe and the
president has been very clear even when
you ask him does a does a border wall
work he said no uh and he's been very
consistent about that we believe that we
need a border technology that is
modernized and land ports of at uh at of
land ports of entry and that's what we
want to see and that's what I can speak
to I love it I love it we just don't
believe walls work it's funny because we
googled it just now every prison in
America has a wall because it keeps
people in and it keeps other people out
by the way have either one of you ever
done fenel because I just realized that
she might be human fenel because every
time every time I play a clip of her I
actually just kind of like slouch over
and I just kind of drool and like I
can't really speak while I mean Sarah
everything with her it's just like she
should be studied one day like the level
dribble right oh for sure I mean it's
agonizing but I I almost feel bad for
her because you really have to believe
just being Joe Biden's press secretary
has to already be the worst job in the
world and then you my sympathy gone well
right but then you factor in the fact
that she's completely incompetent to
begin with and then you're like there's
no way you're saving that um it's
fascinating to watch her say well we
just believe borders don't work I mean
you had the President coming out and
saying I asked for Congress to
reappropriate that redirect the that
appropriated money to pay for something
else because I really don't want a
border wall is just so bizarre to me you
look at the national polling National
Security is polling as one of the top
issues for Americans not just
Republicans I think I read like 57% of
Americans put National Security at the
top of the list and so it's just so wild
to hear Karine jeanpierre say something
so off the- wall like borders walls
don't work what do what doors don't work
locks don't work well what are we doing
in our houses locking our doors at night
if if none of these barriers work I mean
it's just so Preposterous to me and I'll
add one other thing Dave um she
mentioned in the first clip that you
played experts say experts say that that
border barriers don't work and I'm
wondering which experts she talk to is
this like a captain of al-Qaeda who's
like yeah border walls don't work
definitely don't put those
up interior of the country yeah exactly
it's worth noting that you are in a
hotel today right what I'm sorry it's
worth noting that you're in a hotel
today right and because you're in Miami
you're in a hotel right now does that
hotel have a door that maybe would
prevent some people from coming in and
other people does your room that you're
in have a door or any sort of barrier to
the hallway it does and you might be
shocked to know this but you need a key
to get into that door to actually access
he's killing and even once you're in the
room there's a lock on the bathroom door
as well even though I'm the only one
here so um yeah I mean the security is
extra tight here in Miami no that
doesn't work that doesn't work yeah no
that's insane and I I don't understand
this woman at all Karine Johan beir is
the worst press secretary I've ever seen
I thought Jen saki was bad but
jeanpierre is uh so poorly informed you
know she repeats herself she says top of
mind she's still doing that thing top of
mind is even worse than circling back
which I got tired of for sure but yeah I
think that what you were saying Dave is
actually right the Biden Administration
is going to Pivot to vaguely appearing
like they're going to try and crack down
on the border while not actually doing
anything simply because we're going into
an election year and they don't want to
be tripped up on that they don't want to
be called out for their immense failure
here but I think that Republicans and
conservatives really have a
responsibility to hammer what's going on
at the border and to hammer what's going
on in Ukraine because these are massive
um National Security issues we're
spending tons of money in Ukraine to
protect their borders we're doing
nothing to protect our own border we are
losing you know we're losing money here
um because we keep spending all of that
money we're sending all of our arms the
Pentagon says we don't have replacement
ability for those weapons and another
thing too then this was very um this was
not really reported but zalinsky made a
deal with I think 2,000 us defense
companies that made a deal with maybe
like three Ukrainian companies to start
building Munitions factories in Ukraine
so one of the one of the benefits if you
will of War of Waging War for the United
States in the past has been that you
know while it's devastating and all of
that it does uh provide a Big Boon to
our economy we make money on war we make
money on selling weapons um but now if
Ukraine is going to be making their own
weapons where are we going be how what
are we doing like are we just going to
spend money so that they can build
factories and we're just going to like
just keep bleeding all of this money
we're not even doing the stupid thing
we're doing right I think is my point
I'm pretty sure we can always find
another War to go to uh ladies I want to
thank you as always I also uh you can
tell me if I can speak for all three of
us when I say this uh but our criticism
of Karin Johan Pier is directed at her I
love the black lesbian Community I I
consider myself a black lesan lesbian
and I just want to say to you two black
lesbians what a pleasure having you guys
have a great weekend uh we got a
postgame show coming up for our local
subscribers at Ruben report. locals.com
black lesbians white lesbians lesbians
of all stripes are welcome and retired
lesbians whatever we're we're going to
be there in just a second thank you guys
see you later thank you see are not
they're asking what's your advice to the
next next house
speaker
that's a public
paper thank you
[Music]
sir